それではよろしくお願いします
あのね あの この講演とかね
そういうことよりも この慈悲の瞑想はとても大事なことで
よく頑張ってほしいんですね
口先だけのような気がもしますけど
まあいろいろこのトラブったり
人間関係でね 迷惑かけたり
もうちょっと私も年になっちゃってやりきれん状態になってるんです
で これは結局は慈悲は実践していないということですよ
だから こんなややこしい難しい仏教なんかは別に置いといて
すごいシンプルで生きていけるものが幸せでありますようにと
これをちょっと真剣に念じてね
毎朝毎晩念じていけば
何の問題も起こらないんでしょうね
人間 特に人間関係でね
何の問題も起こらないんです
とってもとっても何でもかんでもうまくいきます
ですから まあしっかりと頑張った方がいいと思います
たまたま稀にあの方々はね
慈悲の実践がやっていてね
まあそういう方々は本当にびっくりして私に報告しますけど
これは摩訶不思議なびっくりやと
他の方々はもう協会と関係作った時よりも精神的にひどくなっているという状態になっているんだから
これはちょっと悲しいことです
私にとってはね ボロボロ年になるまで苦労しましたけど
何の結果もないという場合はね
まあだからあの しっかりと慈悲の瞑想を皆様頑張った方がいいと思います
皆様の幸福のためになります
別に私には何の御利益もないんですよ
だから皆様方はね 余計なことで問題を起こしたりしてね
トラブったりしてね 苦労するのはね
それは避けられますからね
そういうことで頑張ってほしいと思います
はい 今日のテーマに入ります
今日は無我についてということで
あの  このテーマになったのはおそらくね
無常とかなんとか喋りましたからね
空については喋ったこと覚えはないんですけどね
この調子になって ついでに無我についても語ってくださいということだと思いますけどね
そんな甘くはないと思いますけど
まあとにかく まあ夏でしょうしね
冷房があっても使えなくなりましたし
で 私は特にあの 暑くなると頭がかなりおかしくなるんです
これはもう体いっぱい脂肪が溜まってるんだから
これ天ぷら状態になるんです
生きたまんまで だから脂肪が温まる
温まるとね もう話になりません
ですから まあ今から私は何言うかという自信も私にもありませんし
その上テーマはね もうとてつもない難しい仏教ではね
テーマでもあるし 全部いい条件揃ってます
まあそういうことで なんとかまあ一般的に
まあここはその専門的なところに入らないで
一般的にまあ少々紹介したいと思います
まあ一応ね 無我といっても
正直なところは まあ私たちにとってはこの無我が理解できません
自分がいるという実感があるんです
そこでかなりもう怒ってね
そんな無我なんか言ったって
そんなのは理解できませんよと平気で言うでしょうに
私が聞きたいのは あんた自我知ってますかと
じゃああたまのこと知ってますかと
これも知らないでしょうに
だからまあそういうことでね
なんかまあ理解しにくいっていうのは
まあまあ一応定義します
まずこの我って我 我っていうね
これはアートマンですね
アートマン で なんでアートマンというインドの単語を使いますかというと
やっぱりこの魂については
このはっきりした思想が発展しているのはインドなんですね
他のどんな国でも ただいい加減で何か言ってるだけで
そんなに真剣に調べたことは全くもないんです
中国もすごい素晴らしい歴史があってね
哲学思考あるんだけど
この魂 霊魂についてはね
まるっきり何も知らない
というか 中国人には物質なんですね
全部 気だと思ってるんだからね
で アラビア文化でもユダヤの文化でも
まあ東洋と西洋文化でも
そんなもう まとめな思考っていうのはまず存在すらしないんです
そういうことですから
このアーツマンっていうのは
まあまあ インドの単語を使うしかないんです
で これはもう紀元前に 3000年前からもう
あの考えていたっていうことは
一応文学的には文献的には記録はあります
ヴェーダ聖典なんかはね
結構古いし まあずっと暗記して覚えてきましたしね
アートマンというのは何ぞやということを考えてはきたんです
まあ英語ではね ソウルとかスピリットとかね
で まあサンスクリット語だったらプラーナ
アートマン まあ日本語だったらまあ我ですね
我と読んでも割と読んでも構わない
それからまあ霊魂 魂 まあ霊とかね
なんとか言葉で何かを表しています
それって一体何なのかっていうことなんです
これは定義としては死で終わらない
死後も続く永遠で不滅で不滅である何かの実体があるという思考
信仰です まあ随分分かりますね
このアーツマンというのは
霊魂というのはかなり頑丈なもので
死んでも変わらないんですね
で 永遠に続くんです それからこれ何かなんですね
何かの実体なんですね
だから我々の体にね 生きているんだとかね
命があるんだと言うんですけど
この命たる本心というものなんですね
これが何や それにこの我とアーツマンと言うんですね
そういうと なんかすごいわかってる顔をしてますけど
わかってますかね そんなのあるかないかと
で これが人間の常識なんです
さっぱりわからないんですけど
わかってる顔をするんです
これはもうアーツマンに対してなんですよ
もう誰でも そこでアーツマンがないと言ったら
なんか鬼扱いされる 悪魔扱いされるんです
お前サタンかいと と言われますよ
それで私がアンタ サタンに会ったことあるんですか？と聞きたくなるんです
で やっぱり人間っていうのは
ただ何かしゃべるだけで無責任なんですね
命があるものの一番大事な
主体 アートなんていうのは
宗教によって 一人間だけの特権にすべての生命にあるという 2つの考えがあります
そこで霊魂というのは
宗教家に聞くと 一部の宗教はあれは人間の特権だと
人間には魂があるんだという宗教もありますし
いえ 生命にはみんなに魂があるんだという宗教もあります
それで人気あるのは 人間だけ魂があるというと
なんか人間随分舞い上がっちゃうんですね
特権があるんだから そういうことで
世界で一番人気あるのは
人間だけに魂がある 動物には魂がないという教えなんです
だから動物は殺しても構わないんです
殺さないで生で食べても構わないんです
生きたままで 魂がないんだからね
で 人間に魂があるんだから
人間を殺してはいけないと言いつつも
平気で殺しちゃいます
動物にも魂があるというと
なんか嫌な気分なんですね
よくできたことですね
人間が性格的に俺だけ偉いというね
ゴキブリも魂があるんだよと言ったら聞きたくもないでしょう
もっと聞きたいのは あなたには特別な魂が宿いているんだよと
特別なもの 一般人にもないんだよと
と言ったらもっとありがたいんです
まあ一応 まあそういうふうに魂について 2つの考えがあります
特色は  1 霊魂が実在する
信じる概念です この日本語わからないんですね
私もわからない 書いたんだけど
あの霊魂 魂の特色 第 1 の特色っていうのは
それは信じるものなんです
あの実験するものじゃないんです
魂があると信じなさいよと
だから楽です 調べたり勉強したりする必要はないんです
はい 信じますと はい 話終わり
ですから まああの 私は何年も頑張ってますけど
ブッダの教えを思考ね
教え紹介しようと でも他の宗教というのはたった２ ３分で終わりますよ
汝は神を信じますか？それで終わり
で はい 信じますと言ったら信じますよ
ああ これ困りますよと
神は信じなきゃ地獄に落ちます
ああ そうですか では信じますと
それで終わりですよ  それから洗礼を受けたら
いろいろ儀式儀礼やったりして遊べばいいんです
だから この これ ややこしい思考する必要はないんです
魂っていうのは信じればいい
あると  2番目の特色は
生命の唯一大切な部品なのに
その存在の立証はできません
だから もう魂について考えるのは人間だけですから
もう人間の体の中にある唯一大事な品物なんです
でも どこにあるかわからないんですね
あるということを立証もできないんです
いまだに誰にもできなかったんです
魂があるということは
証明することは誰にもできなかったんです
が みんな徹底的に信じてはいます
あるということを責められますよ
結局はあんた何言うのかいと
魂があるに決まってるでしょうにと
このあるに決まってるという連中とはもうどう話せばいいんですかね
だから私は一番簡単な手段をとっています
脳細胞は抜かれてますと
だからもう話す必要はないんです
あるに決まってるって言ったら
もう話し合い方法がないんですね
これだからこれだから魂あるんだよと言ったら
それはちょっと調べることはできます
ですから この魂論の特色は
1 信じるものには立証できないこと
証明できない 当然 神という概念と全く同じなんです
で 神も信じるものであって
あんたいるのかいと調べること自体は冒涜になるんです
それから神がいるということは未だに立証できないんです
ヨーロッパの方で頑張ってますよ
立証しようと 昨日インターネットでいくらくらいページ見ていると
ものの見事に自分が立証したつもりで
あの 書いてましたけどね
腹が立って まあ一応何か軽口で何か書いておいたんですけどね
なかなか私は書き入れしませんだけどね
で 何ですかというと 誰かさんの作品がね
紹介して この自然の恵みをね
いろんなちょこちょこと美しい写真をいくつか撮って
こんな素晴らしいことをね
我々には思い存分に与えると
神様ありがとうございますと
だからいるんですね へりこそでしょうね
まあ確かに自然は素晴らしいっていうことはわかりますけど
それは神がくれたっていうことはどうやってわかるんですかね
それだったら地震が誰がくれたんですかね
津波は誰がくれたんですか？それ書いたんですね
それで最後に決まり文句として
英語ではフリーキンという言葉がありますね
あれはふざけるというよね
あのちょっと心配だと
神が地上でふざけているんだから
あいつは天国でもふざけたらもう怖いんだと
地上ではもうろくなこと何もないでしょうに
で たまたまね まあ豊作にもなるし
だから だから神がいると
他全部忘れましょうと
都合の悪い証拠はと こんな話はね
まあまあ信じる方々にとっては
まあそれはちょっとおかしく感じますけど
まあ私たちはね まあ信じません
何も まあ信じるっていう言葉を聞いただけでも
なんか吐き気がするんです
なんか人権侵害した気分になるんですね
子供の頃から私はもうこれ信じなさいと言ったら
ものすごい怒るんです
馬鹿にするんじゃないよと
これ人権侵害なんです
余計な話はどうでもいいんですけど
まあ真面目な話は あの
神と魂っていうのはいつでも同じスタンスなんです
あのヨーロッパでは哲学を発展してないんだから
これはちょっとややこしいんだけど
インドでは神イコール魂なんです
だから魂の本体が 本家が神であって
あの部品というかね あのブランチが我々個人なんですね
あの本社がありまして
魂の 魂の本社が絶対的神様なんですね
そこからいろんなところで
小さな小さな小さな魂の店を開いているんです
それは一人一人の個人なんです
それでヒンドゥー教では人間だけじゃなくて
あの最初は人間だけ魂ありましたけど
なんかまあ紀元...4世紀じゃなくて 5 6
世紀 5 4 3世紀になってくると
なんか動物にも魂があるんですね
面白いんですよ 紀元 3000年の前からもう
年 紀元前八百年までは魂がなかったんで
動物に それからその時代後から出てくるテキストには
もう動物にも魂があって
もうちょっと時代経ると植物にもあるんですね
で これ結構面白いんですよ
いわゆる神様が商売繁盛して
もうどんどんもう あの
何といいますか ブランチをね
商売広げるんです じゃあ植物にも魂あげましょうと
だからそういう信じない場合は
そういう風になんか変に私はからかってますけど
これは信仰するものだから
そんなにバカにしてはいけません
信じるしかないんです
で 植物にも魂があると言ったら
はい わかりましたと一言で言ってください
それで終わり 植物に魂がないと言ったら
ああ そうですか はい わかりました
植物に魂はない これ人間
人権侵害じゃないんですか？そういう風に
だから信仰そのものが私の立場から言えば人権侵害なんです
言う通りに踊れっていうことでしょ
神秘体験 自己暗示 マインドコントロールなどで立証したという人がいるが
正常な人にはわかりません
魂は体験する人々はいるんです
突然 ヨガとか何とかやっていると
もうドカーンと魂がね
神様が降りてきたんだとかね
いう人はまあたまたまいる
で そういう人には立証できますけど
正常な人にはなかなか魂の存在は立証できません
それから 西洋の宗教では
この瞑想とかはね あんまりないんだから
後でどんどんどんどんやるようになりましたけど
あまりないんだから このマインドコントロールという手段を使うんですね
はぁ 見てください もう精霊が受けるんだよとか泣き叫べば
みんななんか興奮しちゃって
体震えて もうもうなんか変なもう見ているとおかしいんじゃなくて面白いんです
教会のメサとかね それで口達者な人があれ喋ると
みんななんかもう頭がいかれたような感じで踊ったり
ぐにゃぐにゃ体をぐにゃぐにゃしたり
もう大変です だからその場合はみんなこの精霊を感じているんです
そういうふうにヒステリー的な症状がない場合は
精霊の存在は知りません
それから この魂の歴史はすごく長いんです
アトマンの だから長いんだから
この絵柄にしたんです
そんな狩りをして生活していた時代からも
魂は信仰してきたんです
アトマンの信仰は 人は自分の存在に気づいた時からあることです
でしょう といいますけどね
だいたい動物は自分の存在に気づいているんですかね
なんかかなり人間ぐらい楽なような気がするでしょ
獲物を見たら追っかけていくだけ
で 家で飼っている猫でも
何か動くものを見たら
もうすぐ面白がって飛んでいくだけで
なかったらゴロゴロと寝るだけでね
別にもう楽にいるんですね
だから人間が自分の存在に気づくんですよ
私がいるんだと そこからいる私は何なのかと
と考えるんです あのヒンドゥー教のテキスト
古いテキストからちょこちょこと参考してみると
この歴史的にこの私がいるんだというね
自分に気づくことから
もうすごい膨大な なかなかわけもわからない
すごい哲学でできちゃったんですね
で 皆様そんなに興味は
皆さんヨガに興味あるんですけど
本当はヒンドゥー教に興味ないでしょ？で
これは失礼ですよ で まあヒンドゥー教でもこの猿を信仰したりとかね
まあそういう程度のヒンドゥー教はみんな興味があるかもしれませんけど
ヒンドゥー教の一部がね
ウパニシャッドというテキストからできた修行をする宗派もあります
このヨガとかは瞑想とかは
その人々は他宗教からパクったものなんです
ヨガはヒンドゥー教のものじゃないんです
で パクられちゃったんです
で あれはブラマン教伝統以外の人々が瞑想していたんです
ヨガという単語さえもパクられちゃったんです
それで学者が逆を言うんです
仏教はまあヒンドゥー教のある概念を使っているんだそうとかね
現実は逆なんですけど
で 仏教からもパクられましたし
ジャイナ教からももう全部教えがそのままもう奪われましたね
はい それでこのウパニシャッドという人々の仙人と言うんですね
リシですね サンスクリット語で
この方々は普通のバラモン人みたいに
この厳誓理役とかね 祈祷とかね
そんなものをやらない
もう真剣に哲学的な物事を考えるんですね
だからまあ 出家の生活して
真剣に考えて この魂をね
知る方法はないのかとかね
で そういう方々はだいたいこの頭でいろいろ魂はこうではないかというふうに言っていたんですね
で そこでこの一般人には教えません
もう理解してくれませんだから
一般人には何とかして
あの 何て言いますか 祈祷してあげれば十分ですからね
それで話が終わり ですから
この真面目な話は聞きたくない
ですから 一部の人々は
この内緒で このちょっと高度な哲学的なことを考え出しました
で だからウパニシャッドと言うんですね
ウパニシャッドっていうのは
まあ内緒で先生のところで隠れて
先生と同居してこそこそと教えてもらうもの
これが本になったらね
何の内緒もなくなっちゃいますけどね
だからウパニシャッドっていうちゃんとしたテキストをね
たくさんあります お釈迦様が現れる前も
そのちょこっと前 ウパニシャッドテキスト出始めたんです
で  3つぐらいお釈迦様よりパーリ経典よりは古いと思いますね
残りはもうパーリ経典できてからまあ作ったものですね
だから後でできたものはすごいわかりやすくて
すごい整理整頓しています
あの哲学思考ありましたから
初期のウパニシャッドっていうのは
まだまだまあバラバラではっきりしないんですね
はい ですから この随分歴史が古いんです
自分がいるという実感について思考すると
何かがあるという気持ちになるんです
どうやってアートマンが現れるか
現れるのかというと 自分がいるでしょ
いくらなんでもこの自分がいるという
この大雑把な気持ちで
だから何かがあるだろうと
自分というもの 何かがあるだろうというふうな
この何か疑問が出てくるんです
なかったらおかしいと
あるはずやと ある だろうは次にあるはずになるんですね
何かがあるはず このあるはずは証明立証できんだから信じなさいということになってくるんです
あるはずっていうことを私たちもよく使いますよ
自分の家では金があったはずなんですけどとかね
見たら金がないとかね
それで誰かに持っていかれたというのはいいんだけど
じゃあなくて もともとなかったってということでもなりますね
だからあるはずであるわけじゃないんです
人間の文明も文化も この概念を前提にして発展したものです
そこで大きな問題ですかね
私たちのすべての文学
文明っていうものは 魂があるという前提でできているんです
小説もドラマも 何でもかんでも
魂を疑いの目で見た作品はないんです
インドでは唯物論というね
すごい優れた哲学派がいたんです
これ 向こうの言葉でローカーエトワードというんです
くたくたやられましたからね
テキストはないんです
たった冊あるみたいですけど
それもそれほど古くないんです
でお釈迦様の時代 もっと前からもこの唯物論を語る人々はいたんです
いわゆる魂がないという話でしょ
しかし あまりにも世界が魂があるに決まってるだろうと言うんだから結構怖いんですよ
だからなかなかうまくいかない
それで彼らが取った態度は
まあ魂があると またこれ
魂は物質でできてますよと
それで一旦なんて言いますか
もうなんて言いますか
もう一応話合いというかね
いくらか まあもうやっていますかね
まあいくらかの話し合いになって
まあもうところで来るんですね
なんか日本語の単語あるんですけど
思い出せません えっ？えっ
折衷 折衷じゃないんです
まあいくらか身を引くことでしょう
普通の日本語で毎日のように使っている単語でしょうね
妥協 妥協です というわけで
唯物論者はいくらか妥協して
魂があるんだよということになったんです
しかし 自分の立場もありますから
この魂が物質ですよと
それが死んじゃったらもう終わり
そうするとまた物質じゃないだろうというんですね
また一部が ああ そうね
あの あの機関 器官がね
感覚器官が魂だと唯物論者がまた言うんです
わかったわかった わかった
また妥協するんです 感覚器官がこの考えたり
見たり 聞いたりする あれが魂ですと
しかし 死んだったら それが空に飛び飛んでいきますよ
終わりと 遺体焼かれたらもうもうぽーっと出て行っちゃいますよ
それではありがとう 言って
自分の唯物論立場も守るんですね
で 面白いことは 唯物論者にしても
魂がないと言えない この状況
すごいんです で 西洋で現れたこのインチキ唯物論もありますよ
科学もそこからなんかどうにもわけもわからない唯物論作ってますけど
で これも哲学者の仕事ですからね
科学者の仕事じゃないし
で そちらもかなりダメージを受けてますよ
あの魂をある魂があると言っている人々
教会とかね 一般人と だから何人も科学を学んでない一般人の方がすごい狂暴で
科学者は折れなくちゃいけないんです
で 共産主義はもう世界からもうくたくた潰れてしまって
潰す潰されてしまいましたしね
で まああの連中はね 政治に手を出しちゃったんだからね
自分の教えもいい加減で
ちんぷんかんぷんでもうむちゃくちゃでしょうし
その上 あの労働者の政府を作ってやるぞとかね
嘘言うなよと言いたいんですけど
どこでも労働者の政府が出来上がったことないんです
いつだって権力者が政権を握っているんです
いつだって搾取する側が権力を握っているんです
それはもう共産主義だからといって変わるわけじゃないんです
まあ微妙に中国ではね
あのマオツェトングが死んでからは
まあいくらか頑張る人になんとか立場が得られるようになりましたけどね
まあロシアなんかは一度もそんなことなかったんですね
だからまあむちゃくちゃ潰れるんです
で 例えば共産主義の国でいえば北朝鮮とかね
あれ 労働者の国ですかね
あのキムというあの神の家族でしょ
皆様方 神様が見たことないでしょう
北朝鮮に行ったらね 見えますよ
だから まあそういう自分が神になっちゃって
まあ搾取するんですよ
だから資本主義っていうのは
お互い様 頑張って搾取し合いましょうと
共産主義っていうのは
一部の人だけ搾取しましょうよと
その差なんです で 搾取する権利はみんなにあるか
一部の人間にあるかっていうことで
共産主義か資本主義かなんです
ですから まあそんな話するのは今日は関係ないんですからね
仏教から見ると悪口言えないところ何もないんです
で それより真面目な話
例えばシェイクスピアの作品にしたっても
魂があるという前提でできているんです
で 日本の昔話にしたっても
魂があるということで話が出来上がるんです
だから私たちには魂がないっていうことで何か考えることはできない
現代 この変な映画とかあるでしょ？このSF映画やらね
エイリアンたちが来る映画やらね
その時でもしっかりとインフィニメスの魂ということは入ってるんですね
そこでサタンの悪魔の魂もありまして
もう神の魂もありまして
もうまあいろいろそういう話で成り立ってるんです
ですから 宗教 哲学 文学
民話などのすべてが 我があるという立場で語られてきたのです
ですから また ですから
ブッダが語られ語れる無我を一般常識的な立場では理解不可能なものになっています
だから我々はもう 6000年前からもう魂があるあるあるあると言われてきたんだから
もう頭ができてないんです
遺伝子もできてないんです
無我っていうことは理解するように
で 長い間生命が進化してきたんだからね
この長い間 もう文明っていうのはこの 2000年前からじゃないでしょ？ものすごい昔
もうね 文明あって壊れてしまったんだからね
だから相当昔から私たちは魂があるというふうに考えて生きてきて
進化してきましたから
今更ね 空を飛びなさいと言っても飛べるわけないでしょ
だって我々もね もう昔空飛んでいたんだからね
一部ぐらいはね まあそれから
まあもう今は飛べないグループも飛べるグループも別々に分かれていて
無我を理解できる知識能力はないんです
これはもう何億年ぐらいもね
魂があるというふうにしてきたんだからね
一応あの論理的にこのポイントを説明します
無我 無我が認識できない理由があるんです
現象は生滅の流れです
これは仏教の話です すべての現象っていうのは固定しているものじゃなくて
ある振動なんですね 生と滅
生と滅 生と滅というふうに
波みたいなもんなんです
で 現れる 消える 現れる
消える これものすごい激しいんですよ
あの電気も同じな 現れて消える
現れて消える あれで電流という流れが生まれるんです
だから物質の生滅はそれほど難しいというわけでもないんです
それはあの生滅はわからないんだったら有無にしてください
有無はそれほどいい言葉でもないんですけど
一応全部使いますね あの
あってなっていうことも使っちゃうし
例えば耳がありますね
耳っていうのは音を感じる感覚
別にこの耳でなくてもいいんです
体のどこかで音を感じる
それに耳というんです
私たちにはね こうやって耳
耳二つもありますけど
ヘビさんにはないんですね
しかし ヘビさんも音は感じます
カエルも音は感じます
耳はないんです ちょっと薄い膜
このカエルの場合はね
目のちょっと後ろにちょっと薄い膜があるんです
それだけ それ触ると目がギューッと中に入るんです
ちょっと痛いでしょうかね
わからない はい それで我々にはこの音を感じる耳がありますね
この耳は生滅あるいは有無の流れで変化しているんです
成り立っています 耳というガンと固体的なものがないんです
素粒子の世界で考えなくちゃダメなんです
体っていうのは原子でできて
原子はもう分子でできていて
まあ素粒子で最終的には素粒子でしょうね
素粒子っていうのは止まるものじゃないでしょ
すべて電気と同じですからね
だから電気と光っていうのは
電気はそれほどでっかいんですけど
まあ光のものはすごい小さいんですね
素粒子としては 電気は結構大きいというかね
で これの世界なんですよ
この体も ですから ずっと振動しているんです
だから耳も現れては消える
現れては消える 現れては消える
現れては消えるという感じで
この交流電気と同じです
耳がうの時 音もうの時
触れたならば音の感覚が起こるんです
そこで耳がうの時 音もうもう無の流れでしょ？あるなし
あるなし あるなし 耳はあるなし
あるなし あるなしなんですね
たまたま耳があるという瞬間で
音もあるという瞬間でぶつかるんですね
そこで反応が起こるんです
その反応が聞こえたということなんです
で 感覚は生まれるんです
しかし 耳が無の時 また耳がうでもうでも音が無の時
感覚は起きません だからそこはちょっとした
あまり立派ではないんだけど
チャートにはしたんです
感覚が有の時 対象も有なら認識もありますね
感覚が有で対象が無だったら認識はない
感覚が無で対象が有であっても認識はない
で 感覚が無で対象も無だったら
また認識はない 認識しないということは
自分にとっては存在もしないんです
知らない あることを このチャートで見ると
存在の場合はステップ 4つあるんですね
4つあるんだけど 我々知っているのは 1個だけ
ですから 無我は認識できないということなんです
以上のチャートで 現象のありのままの状況の 3分の1しか認識していないことになります
そこで現象は 4つの立場持っているのに
私たちは 3分の1しか知らない
ありのままに見ているわけじゃないでしょう
3分の1じゃなくて 4分の1ですね
感覚は眼耳鼻舌身意という六根です
認識対象は色声香味触法という六根です
この説明をする暇がないんです
感覚はナーマ いわゆる心なので
物質的対象により早く
まあこれ 17倍とアビダンマ的に推測できますけど
生滅の振動で変化するんです
まあそんな難しいことじゃないんです
もう体には 6種類の感覚器官があります
それはずっと振動しています
知る機能だから それはナーマ
心にするんですね カテゴライズするんです
外から触れるものは物質なんですね
だから物質はの生滅は遅いんです
生滅 生滅 遅いんです 心はものすごい速く
生滅 生滅ということで
恐ろしい速さで変化するんです
感覚と対象が有時のみ認識して
それが人は知識だとするんです
そこで私たちは見えるものがある時
見る 音がある時 聞く 味がある時
味わう 触れるものが触れた時
触れたと感じるでしょ
それ知識でしょ だから知識は全部あるという知識なんです
無常の知識じゃないんです
ただ 現象は有と無と 2つでしょ
どう見ても物事は変化するのはわかってるでしょうに
大雑把に見てもね もう今日はもう昼は暖かかったし
すごい暑かったし 暖かいところじゃないね
でも この話が終わって出ていくと
まあ涼しいでしょうね
あなたの話聞いたんだからね
氷に富んだって涼しくならないよという話もあるかもしれませんだけど
まあ一応もう話を聞かなかったら
外に出たら涼しいと思います
で それ変化するって意味でしょ
だから水をね ちょっとポットに入れてコンセントさせちゃえば
まあ沸騰する 変化しましたね
だから物事変化するっていうことは当たり前どこにでもあることで
これが認識できないんですよ
これが困ったもんなんです
認識するのはあるっていうことだけなんです
どう頑張っても無は認識できん
だから認識そのものって
エネルギー エネルギーを作るためには何かぶつからないと
で 本当のところはもっと腰が抜けるほど難しいんですけど
これはまあ一般的に まあその程度にしましょう
ですから 生命の知識を総合的に評価すると
ものはある 存在する 私がいる
私が存在するという結果になるんです
だから 歴史上 ものすごい昔からも人間は知識あったんです
物事を認識してきたんです
だから我々は洞窟で生きていた時代から
今も洞窟と大して変わりのないアパートに住んでいることになりましたでしょうね
この長い間 我々は積み重ねてきた知識がありますね
これは全部あるという知識なんです
だから 何か見るたびに私がいる
私がいるという認識が生まれるんです
音を聞くたびに 私がいる
私がいる 私がいるというふうに認識が起こるんです
そこで これは現実の 4分の1だよと
仏教が言っても誰がわからないと
それは 現象には無という立場もありますよと
それがもう まあ推測はたまに知識人にできますけど
推測できるんだけど 経験はなかなかできません
ん？質問していいですか？ はいはい
財布の中に 1万円入ってるっていうのはあるからわかりますよね
財布の中に 1万円なくなったらないなっていうのわかる？ ん？わからない
財布があるだけで  1万円入った時にお金あるなと
だから財布に 1万円 ない財布に
この財布に 1万円がないとどうやってわかるんですか？ 財布を見ればないっていうのは
それ金がないということで
財布があるということでしょ
財布はあるんだけど 金はない
だからその場合は 有状態は 1万円なんです
無の状態は 1万円がない状態なんです
だから 1万円ない財布をワンギーさんにあげたら
ワンギーさんどうやってわかるんですか？買って 1万円ありました
今 1万円がないと わからないでしょ
いや わかりますよ  わからない
じゃあ どなたか自分の財布の金を全部取り出してあなたにあげたら
どうかって どれぐらい金あったとわかる？わからないでしょうね
今何にもないなってのはわかる
だから何もないなということは
この なんていうのは財布があるでしょ
だから財布があるということが助けてくれるんですよ
推測に それで推測するんです
財布とは金が入る品物ですと
この金がある品物が 今金がない
財布だけあると それで引き算して
金がないということになるんです
どうしてもこれはまあある2つで引き算なんです
ないということは認識不可能なんです
例えば我々はね この部屋にいて
ちょっと外へ出る 外へ出て
また中に入ると電気がないと
わかるのは かつて電気があったんだからなんです
突然入った時も この部屋に電気がなかったならば
よくわからないんですね
これはこの部屋の束帯でしょうと何とか言うでしょうね
まあとにかく この まあそういう
まあそんなたとえで理解できるものじゃないんです
このエネルギーのものなんです
だからこちらエネルギーがあって
こちらエネルギーがあって
こうやってエネルギーが触れると
新しいエネルギーが生まれるんであって
こちらエネルギーがゼロだったら
何も起こらないでしょうに
だから これ素粒子の世界の話なんです
例えば私の手にビー玉を落としちゃうと
ビー玉があるんだから
触れたらもうわかるんですね
誰かがビー玉ではなくて
指だけ入ってこうするんですね
何もわからないんですね
何の認識も起こりません
なぜかというと 何も触れなかったんです
そこでビー玉がポンポンポンと手の上で飛ぶ時は
ぶつけた時はわかるし
上へ飛んだ時は何もわからない
またぶつけた時はわかるし
そういうことでしょ だからある時だけわかるんです
何もわからない時はわかってないってことですか？ 別な何かをわかってます
ずっと永続的に我々はうの世界を認識しているんです
で 心は何も認識しないでいることは不可能です
いつでも何かを認識する
ですから心はもう頑固で
いつでもうの世界を認識しているんです
そこはよしとしましょう
もう汗が出ます もう暑いんです
もう簡単にしたいんで
この話は そういうわけで
私たちの歴史がある 過去がある
金があるとかね 国があるとかね
我々の戦争であった猿がいたとかね
あるということもあったという同じことです
そうやってある 存在するというのは人間の認識なんです
ですから 自我はの錯覚がなるんです
6種類の感覚が絶えず生滅変化して流れるのです
しかし 感覚があるという認識しかありません
感覚も生滅の流れです
対象も生滅の流れです
いろんな流れが触れてます
こちらにも流れが 6つです
あの滝 6つやと思ってください
生きる体は 6つの流れです
外にも 6つの流れで そこでも組み合わせてある時だけぶつけて
私がいる 私がいるという錯覚が生まれてくるんです
そこで思考を働かせて私がいる
という正解にならない結論に出すんです
これ精密です 誤解と書いたらまずいんです
正解にならない それだけ
そこで私に見える 聞こえる
そこをまとめて私がいると決めるんですね
そこは正解ではないんです
とんでもない嘘でもないんです
で なぜ嘘ではないかというと
この現象のあるなしの関係で一部だけ
まあちゃんと知ってます
もう 3つありますけど
だから知ってる一部で結論に達しているだけで
だから正解ではありません
まあ誤解とも言えませんね
間違っているとも言えないんですね
なんかややこしいね はい
そういうわけで と言ったっても
どんなわけですかね 私たちには
あの 自分がいるという
確固たる自信があるんですね
確固たる自信があるんです
自分がいるんだという
これが正解ではないんです
完璧誤解というわけでもないんです
さらに 貪瞋痴の感情で練り合わせて
自我 霊魂 魂という錯覚を作るんです
そこで私がいるでしょというのが普通です
あまり怒鳴る必要ないんです
ただ ちょっとこれ正解じゃないんだけどと言えばいいんです
もう惜しいと もうちょっと惜しいやと言えばいいんです
しかし 私たちの欲があるは
怒りがあるは もうきりがないでしょう
その感情で私がいるということは練り合わせるんですね
例えば 私はものすごい欲がありまして
自分の命にむちゃくちゃ執着していて
で 自分がいるという実感もある
そうなってくると 俺は死にたくないやと
なんか死なない方法ないのかと
不良長寿になる方法ないのかとと考えるんです
まあ中国人はもう毒を作って飲んで死んじゃったんだけど
他の人々はそこまでもう頑張らないんですね
だから不良長寿になるんだからって毒を作って飲めばいいのに
それもやらないんですね
そこで頭でごまかしで
日本の政府みたいに言葉でごまかそうとしているんです
そしてそういう人々はこう言うんだ
あのね この肉体は壊れても気にせんでもいいよ
霊魂があるんだから この霊魂は死にませんだから
本当のあなたはこの霊魂だよと
いうと あの欲に絡んでる人にとっては
これが朗報で あの 何といいますか
あの 福 福音 福音ですよ
だから我は神である 汝らには魂がある
もういい加減にしないと
汝らの魂をむちゃくちゃいじめてやるぞというと
まあこの欲ある人にとっては
これはもう福音なんです
ですから この魂という錯覚が
この人間の感情があったんだから生まれるんです
大体動物にも自分という意識が本当はあるんです
だって見えたり聞いたりしてるでしょ？私たちと遊んでくれたりもするでしょ
しかし そんなもう思考する程度の貪瞋痴がないんですね
だからあんまり我論は作りません
それで人間の感情が強ければ強いほど
こういう魂についてむちゃくちゃ考えたり作ったりする
だからこれはもう もうちょっと運転ミスなんです
カーブのところでハンドルを曲げなかったんです
アクセル アクセレーターを踏んじゃうんです
それでドカーンといってしまうんです
それで私がいるという実感はもうしょうがないでしょう
うだけの話ですけど 正解ではないんだけど
まあしょうがない あなたにあなたにできる範囲はこんな程度でしょうと終わっちゃえばいいんです
しかし それに貪瞋痴が絡んでくると
実体がある 魂がある 絶対死なない何かがあるというふうに発展するんです
さらに妄想して 我論 天国
地獄 永遠の命などのイマジネーションを膨らますんです
それからどんどんね 天国があるんだ
地獄があるんだとかね
ストーリー作るわ 作るわ
作るわ あの宗教というのは全部あの御伽話でしょ
アダムの家の話とかね
日本でも小鳥じじいの話とかね
あるでしょうね あれは宗教になってないんですね
同じストーリーは他の文化では宗教になっているんです
あのヒンドゥー教は明らかに神話の集まりなんです
あのマハーバーラタという
ある人が書いた作品 文学作品なんです
今 それが聖典になっているんです
すべてではなくて ワンチャプターだけ
バガヴァッドギーターといって
あれは分厚い とんでもないでっかい本なんですよ
初めから読むと 結構極限に面白くないストーリーなんです
コーランを読むか バガヴァッドギーターではマハーバーラタ読むかというと
私はマハーバーラタ選びますけど
それでも相当苦しいんですよ
読むときは しかし 全部ストーリーなんです
昔々あるところで なんだらかんだらがあって
なんだらかんだら そんなストーリーなんです
その中で パンダワという兄弟のところで戦争が起きちゃって
そこである臆病者 臆病のね
もうアルジュナでしたっけ
もうそいつは戦争したくないんだから
もうクリシュナというもう神がね
もうお化けみたいに現れてきて
戦え 殺せと教えたんです
まあその戦え 殺せというセクションだけはバガヴァッドギーターというんです
神の言葉 でも流れで読むと
別になんのことない ただのストーリーです
そういうことで どんな宗教でもこのいろいろおとぎ話ですよ
宗教と聖典として使っているのは
だから学者がずいぶん仏教に怒っているんです
とにかくこれ どう頑張って何とかしてゴミ箱に捨てたいと
ちゃんとした聖典だから
ちゃんとできていますから
最近 ある学者の本を読んでね
あのパーリ聖典というのは矛盾だらけだと
顔を見たくなっちゃったんで
あの先生の で見なかったんです
なぜかというと 私は警察に捕まれるし
あの人病院に行く羽目になるんです
矛盾だらけで いい加減言うなよ
ちゃんと証拠を出して言いたい
しょうがないんです 有名な学者だから書けばいいやと思っているんです
でも 彼が文学的に 文学じゃなくて
まあ一応文学 文献学的にね
矛盾というのは勘違いで
経典を編集するときはちゃんとテーマで編集して
その時喋ったお釈迦様が喋った他のこともありますから
それ捨てられないでしょうに
メインテーマに合わないんだからカットしましょうとか
もう 現代は編集できますけど
昔はブッダの言葉どうしますかと
ですから 最後にそれもまあ入れておくんです
それ見ればすぐわかります
これはこの経典を編集する時の必要なデータで
流れ作ったところで一部使えなくなりました
しかし それもちゃんと入れておきます
はい  そこでそこで人間というのは自分がいるんだという
この貪瞋痴で自我作ってから
さらにストーリーを作るんですね
いろいろな人やりますよ
例えばインド人の魂論では
まあ魂があるのはインド人だけなんです
あのブラフマという神が作ったのはインドだけなんです
他の国々の人間作ったとはないんです
だからカーストは 4つありますね
このカースト 4つもインド人なんです
で 皆様はブラームのカーストにも入らないし
もうクシャトリヤにも入らないし
何にも入れません だから神がカースト 4つしか作ってないでしょ
だからそれはまあ魂があるのはインド人だけで
これでこちら中東の方に行ってみると
魂があるのはユダヤ人だけなんですね
神が特別に自分の民を作るという
初めからもう魂論があって
えらい自我というかね
傲慢なんですね そこで差別意識
いろいろ排他的思考 いろんなものが入って
あの連中より我々は優れているんだという
私たちは特権を持っているんだとか
いろんなエピソードを作るんです
すべて人間が作った物語であって
科学的な事実 根拠はないんです
生きていたいという欲と死にたくないという怒りがあるから
自我がある いわゆる存在するですね
自我があるという錯覚にしがみつくんです
そこで我々にとっては生きていきたいという欲があります
死にたくないという怒りがあります
あれ 怒りです 死にたくないということは欲じゃないんです
生きていきたいと言ったら
もう欲 死にたくはないと言っちゃうと怒り
その欲と怒りがありますから
我々は魂に存在もしない魂にものすごくしがみつくんです
あのドラゴンボールを探すような感じなんです
あの漫画のね ドラゴンボールというドラゴンボールでしたっけ
もう発音がよくわかりませんだけど
あるわけないでしょうに
しかし 子供たちは一人楽しいんだから
もうドラゴンボールという概念には一応しがみつく
それでいろんな連中が何かいろんなものを作って売って金儲かる
子供たちもカードやらそういうドラゴンボールやらいろんなものを買っちゃいます
興奮して買うんですよ
私たちも同じことやりまして
この自我にしがみつくんです
自我とはドラゴンボールと同じ
いうと錯覚なんです 立証されたことは一度もないんです
そこでお釈迦様が新しいアプローチをしてみるんです
ブッダは人の決まりきった思考パターンで
この問題にアプローチしなかったんです
すべての人類が勉強しているやり方でやらなかったんです
理由は簡単です 必死でが
アートマンを探検 観察
思考 修行 実験などをしているが
誰も答えが見つからないんです
お釈迦様から見れば インドの人類ですね
インドの人類があらゆる方法で魂を探しているんです
苦行するは もう贅沢に溺れるは
いろんなことをやっています
神におねだりするは もう徹夜してヴェーダ聖典あげるは
発音の練習してマントラのね
正しく発音しなくちゃダメですよと
苦労して苦労してアートマンを探してますけど
それでお釈迦様は簡単にこの連中見つかってないんだろうと
見つかってないということは
この方法は間違っているんだと
すごい簡単です  20年苦行したっても
アートマンが見つからなかったら
苦行という方法はダメということでしょう
お釈迦様はえらいシンプルなんです
互い違いの意見が意見ばかり増えるんです
そこで苦行する人は魂はこういうものだと説く
苦行を否定する人は いえ
魂はこういう別なものと言うんです
それで魂論 46ぐらいありましたし
ジャイナ聖典を読んでみるともっとたくさんあったんです
というか あれ 仏教の真似で数増やした可能性もあります
まあとにかく魂は小さいという人がいて
魂はでかいという人もいて
魂には色があるんだという人もいるんですね
この宗教がありまして
魂には 7つの色があるんです
あの 7つも一緒にないんです
虹みたいに 青い魂は青いだけ
赤い魂は赤いだけなんです
だから それなりに人の性格違うだろうと
ほら 証拠あるぞと言うんです
例えばね あの これ あの
参考するテキストないんだから
ちょっと具体的なことは言えないんで
テキストは存在しないんです
このアジヴィカの ですからしょうがないんだけど
この仏典に引用してあるだけで
まあ一応仮にこう思います
例えば青い魂の人がえらい性格が暗いとしましょう
それである人がいつでも暗い
下向いて人と笑わないし
だからといって喧嘩することもないし
引きこもりでぼけーっとしている
そうするとこのアジさんが
ほら この人の魂が青い
だからこの性格 だから魂があるという証拠でしょうねと言うんです
しかし別な宗教があのね
これ魂に色がないんだよと
これは木々と同じものじゃないでしょうにと
好き勝手な色を染められるとかね
何言うのかということに反対する
で 反対できます なぜかというと
アジヴィカの世界ではこの 7つの色があって
純粋な魂には色がないんです
か 白いなんです そこでアジヴィカさんたちは言うんです
我々の魂が白いと ユダヤ教と同じなんですね
結局は考え方は 一番黒い魂あったのはブッダなんです
アジヴィカ宗教から見れば
この何でも否定する ヴェーダも否定するは
儀式も否定するは あいつの魂がもう真っ暗いやと
言って お釈迦様にはいろいろなことを言われましたけどもね
結局は 結局は自分の魂が素晴らしいというためにストーリー作るんですよ
そういうわけで 魂についていろいろ意見があるということは
誰もわかってないということです
ですから 既成の思考方法は正しくないんです
で 釈尊が自分がいるという実感はどのように起こるものかと調べたんです
お釈迦様は精密な科学的に自分が
ちょっといかがあるであるでしょう
だから ここから調べなくちゃいけないんだと
自分がいるということを研究するんです
そこで自我ではなく無我という真理を正解を発見したんです
それでお釈迦様は自分というものを研究したんですね
それで答えが出たんです
自我がありませんと あるのは無我だと
いわゆる我はないんだと
このないということを発見するのは相当難しいんです
科学的な考えで見ても
実験的に見てもないということは
証明するのは相当難しいです
あれということは証明できますけど
そこでお釈迦様の分析ね
五蘊 五取蘊というね それから皆様知ってる仏教ですね
パンチャカンダと言うし
パンチューパーダーナカンダとも言うんです
すべての生命は色受想行識という 5つの集まりです
1 ルーパ 色というのは肉体
物質ですね  2 ヴェーダナーというのは銃ですね
それは感覚のことですね
私たちには肉体があって
肉体の中に感覚があるんです
それから 3番目 サンニャ
想というのは概念 この肉体の中で感覚があって
それからいろいろ概念が生まれるんですね
概念というのは 赤い 丸い
大きい 小さいというふうに思うでしょ
考える前に思うんです
それが それが概念というんですね
サンニャーという それからサンカーラというのは行
欲ですね 座りたい 歩きたい
喋りたいとかね 寝たいとかね
いつでも何か衝動的なのがあるんで
それは行というんです
5番目 ヴィンヤーナンというのは認識ですね
認識すること 感覚があって認識するんですね
それはその 5つの働きで自分ができているんです
この 5つも常に変化するから
無常であって 絶対的に変化しないアートマンにはならない
そこでこの肉体はすーっと変化するでしょ
感覚はすーっと変化するでしょ
外に行ったら涼しいは
部屋の中にいれば暑いはいろいろでしょ
感覚が変わるは変わるは変わる
私のもう喋ってる声を聞くたびに感覚が変わるんです
だから色受想行識っていうのは恐ろしい勢いで変化するんです
変化するんだからアトマンではありませんよと
したがって無我でありますと結論するのです
このお釈迦様の場合 これ理論的なところで言えば
このワンギーさんも言ったように
1万円あったんですけど
今見たら 1万円がないというような感じで
論理的にはお釈迦様はもっと立場が違いますけど
例えばこの中に この体が財布にしましょう
この体という財布の中にアートマンという 1万円があったと思ってはいたんだけど
体を開けてみたら あ  1万円はないというような感じで
無我という結論には立てます
が 最初から 1万円は何やとわからないとどうします？財布の例はよくない
なぜならば我々 1万円わかってますからね
しかしアトマンはわかってないでしょ
はい それから六観と六対象
知る世界からもアプローチします
お釈迦様は 眼耳鼻舌身という六観は常に変化するので
無常であって絶対的な変わらないアトマンではありません
そこで我々は認識しますね
眼耳鼻舌身で これ無常なんですね
絶対的変わらないわけじゃないんです
目が入れる入れるところによって変わるんです
認識に認識を引き起こす
色声香味触法という六大将も常に変化するので
無常であって絶対的に変わらないアトマンにはではありませんと
それで音がずっと変わるでしょ
見えるものはずっと変わるでしょ
味わうものはずっと変わっているでしょ
飴玉でも舐めているとずっと変わっているでしょうに
だからすべて無常なんですね
無常とは変わらない 何かないんだということなんです
対象が触れると起こる 6種類の感覚も
6種類の感覚から起こる 6種類の認識も
無常であって絶対的に変わらないアトマンではありませんと
これ いろんな経典の中身を省略しちゃったんです
もうかなりありますからね
で どちらが無常かというと
目耳鼻が無常 見えるもの
聞こえるものは無常 そこで見える聞こえる
それも無常 それから見えたら楽しいとかね
悲しいとか感覚生まれるでしょ
これも無常 バラの花を見たら楽しいとかね
ゴミを見たらあ 気持ち悪いとか感覚変わるでしょうに
だから無常ばっかしなんです
本当は無常でなきゃ危ないんですよ
例えばどこかでね まあ人を殺して山に捨ててる
捨てていることを見る
見たらぶっけびっくりして怖くなっちゃってね
ヒステリー起こすでしょ
警察に報告しなくちゃって
そこまでも頭が回らないでしょ
で ヒステリー起こしてキャーキャーと泣いたりして
あとで他の人って何で何ですか？と聞いたところで
もう喋れなくなっちゃって
やっと何とか言われたところで
他の人が警察に報告するとかね
あの見た現象は残っちゃうでしょう
あれやばいんですよ もし美味しいご飯を食べて
その味が永久的に舌に留まるとどうなるんですかね
大変やばいんですよ だから無我でよかったんです
変わらない何かあったらとんでもないことになるんです
認識するとき引き起こす煩悩も同じく無常であって
絶対的に変わらないアットモンではありません
はい そんなことで じゃあ無常の説明
無我の説明をしました
無常無我と因縁 を物の流れである現象の
ものありさまを直接認識できなくても
客観的に観察すると 前の現象は後の現象と違っているのだと理解できます
だからこのワンギーさんが質問したのはこれなんです
考えがではなく これなんです
前の現象と今の現象は違ってますよと
それでなんとか 無というものは推測できます
しかし それ無を見たわけじゃなくて
前と後と合わせるんですね
前のうと後のうを合わせるんです
そこでうが変化しているんです
しかし 今まで信仰してきた何かがあるという先入観を使ってはならないんです
だから 皆様方は本当のことを知りたければ
すべての先入観を入れて
あの人はこう考えている
この人はこう考えていると乗ってはいけない
全部間違っているんだから
考えは世の中の 先入観は入らないで直接観察しなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると いとも簡単に無我の発見できます
無常だから無我なのです
したがって 無常イコール無我だと思われても構わないんです
それでお釈迦様が出した答えは無常だよと
他宗教は存在は魂だよと言っているんです
私とは永遠不滅の魂だよと
ウパニシャッドでは有名なフレーズがありまして
タットワマシ それが汝であるという
これはウパニシャッドの場合はね
例えばあの木はあなたに見えますかと
で 弟子が見えますよと
弟子があの木は汝であり
汝はその木であり あの木は汝の我でありと
弟子が首をこうしちゃうでしょ
あの木は私の魂って言ったら
ちょっと先生と思っちゃうでしょ
修行足らんよ それが経験することは本当のウパニシャッドであって
梵我一如であるというふうに説かれてはあります
そこでお釈迦様がまた修行して
私とは無常でありと あの木は無常であり
私も無常であり というのがブッダの答えなんです
別に反対しているわけでも
賛成しているわけでもないんです
中道というか 超越道で正解を出します
それだけ あれ 正解なんです
木は無常でしょう 自分も無常でしょうに
無常なら絶対的変わらない何かあるはずがないんです
この魂っていうのは この流れる川に真ん中に寝るなんかでっかい石のようなものなんです
川が流れても このバカでかい石がそのまんまだよと
そのように我々の体が年取っても
魂がガクンと動かなく不動でいるんだそうと
そんなのあるわけないでしょ
どう見たって そこでおらか者たちは今日は終わらないみたいね
この話は そこでおらか者たちは現象は無常であることは明らかです
こういう現象無常っていうのはね
さっきから言うのはね
そんな子供もわかりますよと
永遠の実体の世界 真理の世界
真我の世界と同一しなくてはならないでしょうという理屈を使うんです
そこで一般人がお釈迦様に反論するんです
木は無常っていうことはね
そんなのは子供でもわかりますよと
私の体もね 命は無常って
そんなのは子供でもわかりますよ
あんた偉そうなことではないでしょ
それはと 偉いことっていうのは
この真我を自分の我と真我を同一させることだと
だから初めからないんだから
そんなのは そういう結論が出るんですね
それでお釈迦様がサッベーサンカーラアニッチャ
諸行無常でありと説くんです
行っていうのは世の中である森羅万象なんですね
それは無常 無常であると
サッベーダンマアナッター
諸法無我であると説くんです
諸法というとすべて入ってます
森羅万象じゃないんです
法の場合は何も抜けてないんです
すべてまとめて無我であると
森羅万象は無常であると
あれ 広げちゃうんですね
無我という概念を使う場合は
法という言葉はわざと使うんです
あの 諸行無我だとないんです
諸法無我です 諸行無常です
なんで諸法無常だと言わないんですかね
例えばウサギの角ありますね
見たことあるんですかね
なんで首を で 一応ウサギの角という言葉があります
人間頭で作った言葉で
皆様飼ってるウサギ以外はウサギには角がないんです
そこでどう思う？ウサギの角は無常ですか
話にならんでしょ 初めからないんだから
しかし ウサギの角というその概念は法に入ります
存在しないんですけど
一つの現象なんです 存在しない
頭でなんか組み立てた幻覚じゃない
あれは ちゃんとした思考です
ウサギの角っていうのは
しかし それ存在しないんだから
無常とは言えませんが
無我とは言えますね だって実体ないでしょ
このペットボトルは無常です
あるんだからね 同時に無我です
実体はないんです そこで無我という単語を使う場合は
諸法と言わなくちゃいけないんです
行っていうのは これちょっとした辞書定義ですね
行っていうのは 因縁によって起こる現象
法っていうのは 涅槃も含むすべてのもの
涅槃もウサギの角も亀の毛も空毛も全部入ってます
法といえば それは無我
涅槃も無我 はい 因縁のこと
ちょっと考えておきましょう
一切の現象は因縁によって現れるのです
人間に発見できてもできなくても
因縁がなく 原因がなく
偶然 突然 そうそうによって何かが現れるのではありません
人間が馬鹿だから これは偶然
これは突然 これは神が作ったとかね
言うでしょ ただ あんたバカ
それだけなんです 例えば私も
あ 偶然だっていうのは
私はその原因など知らないんだから
だけでしょ 突然今日は人が決まったよということは
その人が先にできます
いなかったんです 今日伺いますよと来ると思わなかったんです
だから突然 今日は突然人が決まったと言います
別に因果法則なんです
だから偶然 突然 それからそうそうという単語を使うと
その意味はあんたバカ
それでは アホかと ただ本人がわかってないだけ
科学の世界でもわかってないものはいっぱいあります
そこでまとめな科学者はまだまだそこまで研究していないんだよというだけ
どうしますかね もう時間なんですね
半分も進んでない 今日は
9時過ぎまで まだ今 8時
今まだ 8時半です まだ30分
はい 私にとっては 私にとっては 10時まで喋ったぐらい元気です
これ この今日の話には区切りないんです
くぐりでは一行一行くぐりなんですよ
これはもう相当難しいところはもう
誰にでもわかるようにしたんですね
これ 誰にでもわかるようにしたらこんなもんなんです
だから絶対本物は勉強しないことにしてください
で 原因によって生じるものは
その原因に支えている時のみ存在するんです
因果法則というのはそういうものなんです
今 蛍光灯が光っている
これ偶然 これ 神様の大慈悲の結果
何でもないでしょ 原因知ってますね
しかし 蛍光灯の光はすーっと原因で支えてもらわないと
ピシッと消えます もし因果法則がなかったら
我々は冬はガンガン冷房をかけられますよ
だって一旦もう冷房を回したら
もうすーっと回ってくれるでしょ
そうじゃないんです すーっと電気という原因を供給しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから残念でしたね もう節電しなくちゃいけないんです
世界一技術の優れている原発は壊れて壊れましたからね
はい これから世界一のものを作らないでください
なぜかというと 他の国々でも原発はありますけど
一つも世界一じゃないんです
安全対策は ですから大丈夫です
そんなことはどうでもいいんですけど
まああの蛍光灯の光は原因によって支えていますが
すーっと原因は支えないと光がなくなるんですね
因果法則というのは その話です
原因が消えると結果もなくなるんです
ですから 絶対的で常住する実体アートマンは
観察能力が乏しいから起こる錯覚以外何でもありません
この世の中である膨大な我論
アートに対する知識っていうのは哲学
膨大ですよ あれは単純に観察能力が乏しい
それだけ 因果法則から見れば
なんだこの人々はということになるんです
サッベーダンマアナッタ
諸法無我という結論は
現実的な因縁の法則を理解することの結果なんです
お釈迦様は実験すると因果法則ということがわかっちゃったんですね
そうすると結論としてサッベーダンマアナッタという結論は本文に書きました
ということです これはお釈迦様の悟りの結論ですね
はい それで困るのはね
自我がない 無我だよというと
私はどうなるんですかね
無我という ここでちょっと休憩しましょう
今時間もないんですから
まあ一応さっさと飛ばしてみましょう
で 無我という 無我とは誤解しやすい用語です
この無我無我っていうのは誤解しやすいんですね
私はいませんという意味になってしまうんですね
無我といったらね 仏教は何言うのかという感じになるんです
人には感覚によって起こる自分がいるという実感があるんです
目耳鼻から私たちは私がいるんだという実感を作っているんです
我がアトマンのことです
こちらで無我の我っていうのは私という意味じゃないんです
これはアトマンのことなんです
無我はアトマンがないという意味なんです
無我っていうのは あなたはいませんよという意味じゃなくて
永遠不滅の絶対的で変わらない
何か知るものはないんだよという話です
君はいるんだけど ですから
これはあくまでも仏教の哲学的な用語でしょ
アトマンとは宗教家が妄想してして形而上学的な指定じゃなくて妄想した
妄想した形而上学的な概念です
我々素人に関係ないんです
アーツマンは一般人がそんな考えたこともないしね
これ宗教家なんですよ
この頭イカれていろんなことを考えるの
精霊が降りてきましたとか
魂がもう浄化しましたとか
こんなのもうもう一部の宗教家たちがごちゃごちゃ考える
妄想する形而上学的な概念なんです
アーツマンは 仏教は形而上学ではないんだから無我と言うんです
絶対的で変わらない実体
実存する神なのです このアーツマンというのは
我々の中で何か神があるんだよと言うんだけど
本当はないんですね 絶対的神ブラフマン
神が個がの話です 皆様もこのヒンドゥー教とかなんか学ぶときは聞いている
耳に入る言葉でしょ 絶対
絶対的神っていうのは西洋でブラフマンという言葉
神がという言葉 コガという言葉は聞いてるでしょう
あの話なんです だから一般人にはもう全く関係ない話なんです
アーツマンは だから一部の宗教家たちが
オタクたちですね この宗教オタクが考える概念ですよ
これに私たち引っかかって
なんで長い難しい講演しなくちゃあかんですかね
それは放っておけばいいでしょ
無常わかればいいのに
無常は関係あるでしょう
だって作った家が津波で流されちゃうとありがたくないでしょうに
だから無常はやっぱり大いに興味ありますけど
我はね 我も蚊も嫌なんでしょ
虫だから そういうことで無視しても構わないんです
ですから 時間が間違えた
無我とは 無我とは私はないではなく
私と私のアーツマンと言える
絶対的で変わらない神がありえないという意味なんです
私がいないという意味じゃなくて
私たるもの 私と言えるべくべく
何かこの神 そんなのはないんだよ
と 様々な因縁によって変化してゆく自分
自己と表現できる流れがあるんです
朝から晩まで変化 変化
変化ばっかりしている自分が
いるんです ただ変化するんですね
朝の自分と今の自分が相当違うんですね
それは一つの流れなんですね
自分という実感もあります
しかし これがどのように起こるものかと説明もできます
この自分という実感があるんだから
それ説明できます 魂の説明はできません
立証することもできます
アートマンは立証できませんだけど
自分という実感は立証できます
何が変わっても絶対的に変わる
絶対的な変わらない我はあり得ないが
瞬間瞬間変わる自分がいるんです
そんなもんです 瞬間瞬間変わる自分がいるんです
しかし 絶対的に変わらない自分はいません
自分とは因縁の流れなんです
それでお釈迦様のというか
スッタニパータのアッジャッタウパサンタッサナッティアッタクットーニラッタは
心の安穏に達した人には我という実感はない
当然無我という実感もないと
もう我も無我もどうでもいいやと
悟りに達したら それはものすごい難しい経典の一部ですけど
こんな風に取り出すとちょっと誤解しますけどね
妄想することをやめなさいという経典なんです
妄想ではなく ねつ造すること
自我の錯覚で困る 本当に自我で困りますよ
我は究極の至福だと思われている
このインドの宗教では
魂というのはアートマンとは究極の至福であるというんですね
しかし 至福そのものであり
真があるのに 現実は生きることは悩み苦しみで満ちているんです
言うだけは言うんだけど
あなたの汝の体に至福たる神であるアートマンがありますよと
本当かいと 朝から晩まで苦しい人生でしょうに
一度でもああ 至福感やとか感じたこともないでしょうに
罪のせいという 言ってますかね
我は罪を犯します 犯しますかと
そこで私はキリスト教の方々にも聞いたことは
でもなんでそんなにジャイジの神がね
こんなひどい目に遭わせてますか？と言ったら
これは汝らは罪人だからやと
で 聞きたいのは この永遠不滅の魂が罪を犯しますかね
だってあれ変化しないものでしょ
魂やら我やら言ったら
その野郎が罪を犯すはずがないでしょうに
もう屁理屈すぐいいところなんです
我は罪で汚染されるなら
我が様々な原因によって変化するのになってしまうでしょ
それで宗教で言うでしょ
魂は汚れますよと 魂は清らかにしない
魂って何ですかね？簡単に汚れるんですね
簡単に清らかになるんだから
あれは魂じゃないでしょ
それだったら 永遠不滅の
だって簡単に汚れますから
だから魂論を持ってくると
罪はありえなくなっちゃうんです
魂っていうのはプラスチック樹脂でできているようなもので
何の変化も起きません
それから至福なんです
魂が苦を感じるはずがないんです
だからこの矛盾はブッダの時代でも発見したんですよ
だから ある宗教家が魂は至福やというと
ある宗教家が いえ 魂は究極苦であるとも言うんです
それに腹が立って もしもし他の宗教が
いえ 魂は時には至福 時には苦を感じるんだと
それに腹が立った他の宗教家が
そんなのは魂に対して何とも言えませんよと
という態度を取るんだ
まあどちらでもバカということです
ですから 我説と悪の存在は両立できません
これ怖いんでしょうに
これ霊魂がある魂があると言っちゃうと
人間が罪を犯してもいいんです
だって霊魂は影響を受けないものでしょうに
あの 例えばね 人を殺しても魂は殺せないでしょ
勝手にやってください
裁判で捕まったらね 裁判官に言ってください
あのね 裁判長 これ肉体は滅びても霊魂は滅びれないんだよ
私はあいつ蹴っ飛ばしてね
車にはねたんだけど 魂は健全だよと
だから裁判官にあんたバカかい？と
こんな尊い真理を知らないのかと言ってみてください
あの皆さん 日本 日本ではね
とても有名な人がね まあ人殺すのは良いことであると
最終解脱にはその権利があるんだと
殺した方が善行為だと
でないと一般日本人が罪ばっかし起こして地獄に落ちるでしょ
だから人が 80年間生きてると
八八十年間も罪を犯すでしょ
だから 30歳で捕まって
戦災さんの自分の名義変更変更してもらって
あの 殺すんです あの あったかい熱いお風呂に入れたり
いろいろ治療したりして
それから一発でサリ巻け巻いた方がもっとたくさん善行為になりますということで
まあそれ頑張ったんです
だから魂なんか信じちゃうと
大量殺人じゃなくて日本国民全滅させちゃってもいいんです
だって魂は痛も痛くも痒くもないでしょうに
だからとんでもない概念ですよ
道徳的に見ても 絶対的な我があるならば
悪を犯しても善を行っても
我には与える影響はありません
無常だから無我ですね
自己の改良改善できます
ブッダが無常やと言うんで無我というんですね
だったら大変ですよ 仕事しなくちゃあかんです
改良しなくちゃあかんです
改善しなくちゃあかんです
無常だからできます 道徳は成り立ちます
無常論で道徳になります
成り立ちます 無我論で道徳がなりますけど
成り立ちますけど 世の中言ってること
魂がないというあなた方はという
すごくあの 見下されますよ
それから流れの勉強をしましょう
よく写真で見えないんですけど
これでどこかの汚いものが流れてくる川なんです
あの外流れ流れという単語を使ったんでしょ
因果法則と流れ あの川を流れる水を観察
川のかな 川をでもいいし
流れる水を観察してみましょう
ちょっと一休みして川を見てください
あるいは流れる水 川でなくてもいいんです
見てください 我々に体験できる観察する
この辺になってくると相当疲れているでしょうね
結構観察できる あると思える川があるんです
それで川を見ようと思ったら観察できる
川があるんですね あるとも言えますし
観察もできる 荒川 隅田川
多摩川などの名前をつけることもできるんです
しかし 荒川には荒川だというべき
絶対変わらない 荒川の芯だと言える何かがありますか？そんな難しい顔をしなくても
そこら辺に隅田川とか荒川とか多摩川あるでしょうに
皆様 あれ何川ときたら
あれ 多摩川だよと言うでしょ
へっちゃらで では多摩川に多摩川というべき芯
何かありますか？とか
何もないでしょ 川が瞬間瞬間変わってしまうんです
多摩川であろうと荒川であろうか
ただの川で 溝の中に水が流れるだけで
あれは瞬間瞬間変わるんです
気づかないだけですが
瞬間瞬間川の中身が変わるので別々の川なんです
20秒川を見ると  20回違う川なんです
川を見るために 1 秒かかると推測しましょう
川を見るために 1 秒かかります
それで 20秒川を見ていると
川が二重なんです 二重
二重 川はどうやって数えます？え？川を数える場合はどんな
おそらく 1石 2石じゃないでしょうね
1本2本でしたっけ まあ仮に 1本2本にしましょう
で  20秒川を見ていると
20本の川を見ているんですよ
ただ気づかない それだけ
本当は水が出ていて 新しい水なんです
しかし 絶えず流れるので荒川と言えますよ
だから 20分 あなた何を見たんですかと
私は 20分  20秒間 荒川第1
荒川第2 荒川第4 荒川第5を見たと言わないでしょ
いや あの 20秒間荒川見てましたよ
と言うんですからね 生命の存在も因縁によって起こる現象なので
流れなんです 私も皆様も荒川
隅田川と同じなんです
流れなんです 生まれた赤ちゃんと自分が相当違うでしょ
でもまあ同じ名前使います
スマナサーラ一がこのホールに入って
スマナサーラ365が出ていくわけじゃないんです
そんなややこしいことを言わなくても
スマナサーラが入ってスマナサーラが出て行っちゃって言えばいいでしょうに
そこで頭が悪い連中は
実体として同じスマナサーラが出てきて
同じスマナサーラがもう入ってきて出ていくと言うんですね
あれがバカなんですね
それだけ もう川のように流れるんです
従って無我です 私たちはみんな
自分という流れを汚さないこと
だから無我だから心を清らかにする義務が出てくるんです
川だから川を汚してはならないでしょう
川が入るものによって汚れてしまうんです
私たちの体も同じでしょ
体に入るものによって汚れるんです
言葉 食べるものによっていろんなことで汚れるんです
我々の人生も眼耳鼻舌身意という感覚器官に入る情報によって汚れるんです
ものを見て心は汚す 音を聞いて心を汚す
喧嘩もする 怒る 怒鳴る
あれやこれやとかね ただ音を聞いただけ
テレビのニュースを聞きながら
みんな落ち込んだり 腹が立ったり
こんな野菜食べられませんよとか
いろんなことを言ったりとか
いろいろ変わりますね
だから心が汚れるんです
ですから 貪瞋痴の汚れが入らないように
感情が氾濫しないように自己制御するのです
だから仏教はね 自己制御しましょうと
こう 川ですね 川に汚れが入っちゃうと
ものすごく汚れてしまってひどい目に遭うんです
あるいは逆に氾濫したらまたやばいんでしょ？だから
きれいな美しい水がゆったりと流れるいい川にしてほしいんです
人生は 感情の氾濫もダメ
貪瞋痴という世襲やらね
そういうもの入ってもダメなんです
そのうち治りますという話を世の中でやりますね
時間が経てば治りますと言うが
世の中よく言うでしょ？例えば自分が怒っていて
もうカンカン怒っているんですね
まあ放っておきましょう
まあ時間経てば治りますよと言うでしょ
しかし ちょっとおかしいんです
時間経てば治るわけじゃないんです
川に 人生にも 汚染物質が入ることをストップしない限り
清らかにはなりません
だから人がカンカン怒った
何言っても聞いてくれない
それで私はまあいいや
放っておきましょう そのうち治るだろうと
しかし その人がスーッと怒りを回転するとどうなりますか
あの川がきれいにならないんです
だから一旦私という川に大量の放射物質が入ったとしましょう
まあ最近人気ありますからね
汚れの放射物質にしています
大量の放射物質が入ったとしましょう
それから入らないならばきれいになります
入りっぱなしだったら
いくら放っておいても
福島のほうの海と同じくなっちゃうんですね
漏れるは漏れるは漏れるは限りがないんです
それで検査しなきゃいいんです
それで OK です データ取らないことにする
だから川は流ればきれいになるということは
汚れた時 それから汚れてないっていうなんです
そこをちょっと理解してください
私たちも怒ったり欲張ったりしたら
時間は直してくれませんよ
あれはちょっとした勘違いなんです
なんで子供死んだんだろう
なんで家が潰れたんだろうとかね
毎日泣いちゃうと心が直らないんです
なんで津波で家族はみんな亡くなっちゃって
私だけ残ったんだろうとかね
これ毎日思っちゃうと
自分という川に毎日汚染物質が入ってるんですね
だから時間が直してくれますよ
その度にはストップしなくちゃいけないんです
汚染の流れを だから妄想はやめるしかないんです
貪瞋痴の妄想はやめちゃえば治ります
で それから無我と解脱の関係
人生とは 瞬間瞬間変わるものです
悲しみも楽しみも瞬間のことです
価値がある経験 感覚だと思うものも瞬間で消えるんです
人生大事なことを経験しましたと言っても
たった瞬間です 何でも瞬間です
現象には執着するに値するものはないんです
すべてあっという間に消えるんだから
取ろうとするともう消えているんです
シャボン玉と同じですよ
美しいシャボン玉が出てくると
あ なんて綺麗ですか ちょっもう消えているんです
だから取らん方がいいんです
人生はうたかたのようなものです
囚われることで 執着することで得るのは苦しみ
悩み 苦しみのみです だから皆様も自分でないのに
この国は自分の国だと思う
自分の家でもないのに
この家は私の家だという
言ってるでしょ これは私の家族だと
いるわけないでしょ これ私の体よ
そんなこと言える？何一つ私のっていうのはないんです
勝手に変わるんです 私の体といっても
体が勝手に変わるんです
川と同じなんです だから自分でないものに自分のもの
自分のもの言ってもう苦しんでいるだけ
だから無常をわかると無我わかると
あ そんなもんかいと うたかたかいと
シャボン玉かいと すべてはとわかるとすごい安らぎを感じるんです
この事実に目覚める人は
無執着に興味を抱くんです
無常と無我をわかってくると
もう執着の方がいいんじゃない？という気分になるんです
これちょっともう瞑想する人々の
ちょっとレベル高いところを今書いてるんです
皆様が思っている無執着とは違うんですよ
結構レベルが高いんです
やっぱり無執着の方がいいという風になるんです
無我を認識する瞬間 そこで無我を認識するんです
無我の認識は不可能だと初めに述べました
ね 講演の初めに しかし
観察瞑想を実践して集中力を上げると
因果法則を見えてくると
存在のからくりが現れてくると
これはお釈迦様の言葉でパートバヴァンティダンマという単語なんですね
ダンマがあらわになるんだと
ありのままの状況を自分に
心が無執着の方向へ赴くんです
煩悩が起こらない状態を期待するんです
川の流れですけど 煩悩が起こらない
無執着の状態が欲しいというすごいエネルギーが生まれてくるんです
その瞬間で無我を体験するんです
そこまではできます 認識するのです
だから人生一回は無我を認識できます
それが解脱です まあ悟りは４段階ですから ４
回できますよ それからも清浄
清浄状態を作ると 悟りに達した人々には好きな放題無我に入っていることができます
これは科学的に理論的に成り立たないんです
無を認識するということはね
だからビー玉で考えると
ビー玉手にの上にポンポンと当てる時は感じるんであって
当てない時に意識しますと言ったら
ちょっと成り立たないんですね
しかしそれができます
はい それから結局は仏教
非物質の世界になります
だからもう人間にはもう理解できないんです
もう非物質も非ナームの世界になるんです
はい それから最後にブッダの教えで
長いね じゃあまあ日本語訳でいきましょう
アッゲメッサナよ 私はこのように弟子たちを戒めます
このように頻繁に語ります
比丘たちよ 色は無常 受は無常
想は無常 行は無常 識は無常です
また 色無我 受は無我 想は無我
行は無我 識は無我です
諸行は無常です 正法は無我ですと
私はこのように教えてますよとお釈迦様は見事にあるところでまとめています
これはマッジムニカへの 45番目の経典で
チューラサッチャカスッタン
これ面白い経典です 皆様にも日本語がありますから
読めば結構面白いと思います
なんかエピソードっぽく書いてますけど
内容はすごい理論ですけど
結構面白く書いてます
作ってます こういうことで教演は終わりまして
もし時間が余ったら救援にコーナーやろうかなと思ったんですけど
時間が余るところじゃないんですね
どうしますか 空と無我は無我の関係
まあ救援だからね 空と無我の関係って何ですかと
初期仏教では空無常 無我
苦 ほとんど同じ意味で使います
空論のように 何かの哲学概念を極限に伸ばして哲学を作ること
思想体系を作ることにはにお釈迦様は大反対です
お釈迦様は素晴らしいことを教えますけど
自分が教えた言葉を取って哲学を作るなよと
思想体系を作るなよと
仏教の中では中間派とか空論は一つの体系を作ってはありますけど
本当はそれはお釈迦様なら反対ですね
空は嘘とは言わないんだけど
そういうふうに宗派を作るなよということなんですね
学派 論があると異論が成り立って論争になります
時間の無駄に時間は無駄にします
1 日早くも清らかな心を作ることが初期仏教の立場なんです
あんた論じる暇があったら
早く心を清らかにしなさいと
空は虚無主義と間違える可能性があるので
パーリ聖典ではそれほどハイライトはしないんです
無常はハイライトします
空はあるんだけど あまりハイライトしない
誰か誤解したら困ります
で 空論を作ったナーガルジュナもひどい目に遭いましたからね
それから本人にも自分の仏教そのものも成り立つことができなくなっちゃったんです
もし意味は同じであるならば
なぜ無常 空 無我という 3つに分けたのですか？という質問に
それは人々の理解する方法は様々だからなんです
無常という概念に興味を抱く人も
空という概念に興味を抱く人もいます
誰にでも理解できるように
仏教の真理をユニバーサルにしています
ユニバーサルって何でしたっけね
ある一つの用語に固まらないんです
みんな使う 使う用語 みんなの興味ある用語を全部使ってユニバーサル
するんです 誰にでも使えます
使えますよと だから無常
苦 無我って 3つも使ってます
日本の IT 製品を作る時見られるガラパゴス思想とは正反対
仏教は 日本では何を品物を買っても
うちの会社と他の会社
何の相性も整合性も何もないんですね
だから一番困っているのは携帯なんですね
日本の携帯は日本だけでしか使えないんです
世界一技術ですけど どこにも使えません
どこででも だからそこってこの閉鎖思考でしょ
だからこの例えば唯識論
なんて今空論とかね どこかで閉鎖ですね
真言密教になってくると
ものすごい閉鎖思考 これは仏教ではないんで
仏教はガラパゴス現象はもう大反対です
ユニバーサル オープンソースです
オープンなんて言いますか
ん？オープンソース 苦
無常 無我以外 病気 出来物
蜃気楼 幻覚 燃える炭などなどいろんな言葉で説明してますよ
クソという言葉を使う時もあります
存在はクソであると だからそれ
あ そうですか とね 興味を持つ人はいますよ
だからこうという風に言っちゃうと
ちょっとみんなのみんな興味を持って
あ 頑張らなくちゃという風になってもらわないと
だからあの苦 無常 無我
3つだけじゃなくて またたくさん単語仏教で使ってます
はい 次 無常 苦 無我の関係はと
ここであのアンニッチャと書いてありますね
ここ 無常っていうのはほとんどの人々に理解しやすい
ここはほとんどの人々に理解しやすい
このアンニッチャというところ
そこでドッカっていうのは苦でしょ
感覚的に物事にアプローチする人にわかりやすい
感覚的には苦しいな 大変だな
この人生は とかね 思う人にとっては
苦の方がよろしいんです
無常っていうのは 別に苦しみに興味なくても
まあ世の中は無常だよっていうのは大体かなりの人々は無常に興味を持つんです
その中で一部は世の中
一部は苦に興味を持つんです
3番目の無我は あなた
無我は宗教家 思想家 精神世界に興味ある人にわかりやすい
逆にわからなきこともあります
あまりにも我論に執着するとわからなく
わからなくて頭が壊れるとどうしようもないんですよ
あまりにも自我 自我 自我論考えると脳が壊れるんです
だって存在しないものを存在すると思うんだから
そうなってくるともうお手上げ
そうではなくて あの人は何言ってるか
この人は何言ってるかとかね
そうやって調べる人にとっては
無我はアクセスしやすいんです
そういうことで この人の性格に合わせています
無我論と因果法則は関係がありますかと
大いに関係があります
因果法則は釈尊が悟りによって発見された真理です
お釈迦様は無我を発見するために修行してないんです
お釈迦様は一応苦しみをなくすために修行したところで
因果法則を発見したんです
これはお釈迦様が発見した真理なんです
真な仏説です 真理を発見できなかった思想家たち
宗教家たち また一般人も
永遠不滅の身体がアートマンがあると固く信じて論じているのです
お釈迦様は世の中を見ると
全然答えが見つかっていない
人々は魂があるんだ 魂があるんだと非常に固く信じているんですね
それに応えて あ この人に答えなくちゃいけないんだと答えて
我は実際しないとブッダが語っただけ
だから世の中の質問に答えただけなんです
お釈迦様に別に無我論を語る必要ないんです
無我論とは言葉ですが
仏教には因果法則が真理で
無我論なんかはありません
仏教は我論でも無我論でも何でもないんで
因果法則なんです ただ
世の中は我があるでしょと言って
え ないんだよと言うだけの話
もし誰かさんが人間の心臓の中に十ミリ玉の水晶が必ずあるんだよと言ってきたら
お釈迦様は人の心臓の中に水晶玉がありませんというだけで
あのバカがそんな話を持ってこなかったら
こちらもそんな話はしないんです
だから世は我論を語らなかったら
仏教は別に無我論を語る必要はないんです
しかし ブッダが因果論は語ります
変わらない実体がないからこそ
因縁によって森羅万象が変化していくのだと因果法則で発見できます
で 私のアイデンティティはありますかと
あなたは一つの滝 小川だと思ってみてください
中身は瞬間瞬間変わりますが
俗世間的に滝がある 小川があると言えるでしょう
だから私のアイデンティティは何なのかと思う人が
自分が小川か滝だと思ってください
滝と言ったってもすぐ変わるでしょう
でも滝はあるんですね
これがこのアイデンティティです
あってないようなものなんです
滝があってないようなものでしょうに
だから自分もいるだけど
いないようなものでしょ
しかし 滝 小川を管理したり
汚れないようにしたり
皆の役に立つようにしたりすることができます
滝があったら滝を綺麗に管理して
みんなのためにみんな喜ぶようにとすることできますでしょうに
だから自分という滝もそのようにすることができます
私たちも存在もしない自我は自我を張るのではなく
自己管理して自分にも他人にも役に立つ人間になるんです
このために自分が選ぶ道は自分探しであり
アイデンティティの確立でもあります
はい これで一応全部完結です
簡単ですよ 自分探しっていうのはもう滝ですからね
滝は管理して 自分の他人の役に立つようにすれば
その方法が自分の道であって
自分のアイデンティティなんです
はい 終わり  ありがとうございました
あのだいぶ時間が押してしまいましたけど
最後に回向の文で終了したいと思います
皆さん合掌してください
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに
行をいたします この功徳によって
すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして狙いが得られますように
サッビーティヨー ヴィパッジャントー サッバーローゴー ヴィナッサトゥマーデーヴァー トゥワンタラーヨー スケーディーガー
ユコー バヴァ バワトゥ サッバ マングラング ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバ ブンターヌ
バーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマーヌバーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティー バワントゥ
テー アビワーダナ シーリッサ ニッチャーング ヴァッダパチャイノー チャッタールー ダンマ ワンドンティー ターユワッノー スカング バラング
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ